floss and my little puppy paw pads are
really hurting right now this could be a
lot worse how could this get worse huh
how could it get worse
well it's no surprise that Will Farrell
and Jamie Foxx are a great
Duo and play great off of one another I
have to say the same you know for
Randall and I love just just like the
four of them like we did get them all
recording together a couple of times
they just are such skilled comedians
with so much experience that they really
know how to play off of one another in a
really imaginative and playful way that
makes you feel like you're really with
like a cool gang of dog friends and and
I don't know I just found it I just
never wanted to leave that session I
recently this couch
of my life
really yeah and she dirty too I see you
later baby it was nice to meet you so
much improvising and they wanted to
perform together that was part of the
appeal for them I think and for Jamie
and Will in particular they did I think
pretty much every session together
uh and being able to play off of each
other LED them to some crazy places and
you know Josh would you know like
encourage them to like you know go run
with whatever idea they had we would be
in the booth like texting Josh being
like what if they try this what if they
tried this and they would uh and they
would take it in there you know these
are some of the best people to ever
uh do it they're the best improvisers
and multi-talented uh comedians uh that
have ever existed and for them to be
able to be
um playing off of each other was a joy
for them as much as it was for us in the
booth and then as much as it was for the
audience whoa you look different you
look different too how so is it my human
hands hold up that was a really fun uh
secret sequence to work on you know it
was a thing where we were like okay
let's all come together and like pitch
what kind of crazy things could happen
and you know it was it was built in the
edit room and we're like well let's try
this let's try this
you know uh part of it was sort of like
oh look at this oh here's I found a dog
puppet online that looks kind of like
Hunter what if we what if we did that
and then somebody else was like well
what if we put uh human hands on him uh
and it was a big a fun group activity to
sort of see what we could do to sort of
surprise each other and and a lot of
people
uh came together to to do that and it
was a fun experiment because you could
do anything anything you could think of
we could we could do and uh and we tried
a bunch there's got to be a couple dozen
versions of that scene uh that with a
bunch of things that were even too crazy
it was like a floating tennis ball right
that was something about Sarah Lawrence
College
uh there was a lot of weird stuff that
was tried uh and but this was the uh
this was the most the most fun ones I
think we we got
[Music]
oh yeah yeah I know I should probably
take it off no no it's growing oh my God
oh my God probably I would imagine uh
that there there could be the extended
mushroom cut uh there were you know
that probably Cuts plural that's right
yeah definitely there was a lot
but what's really great about Josh uh as
a director is that he really knew what
he wanted and he was also really open to
you know
this group of very talented people these
actors that would like could provide
something fun and be like okay let's go
with that and then we'll figure out how
to get it into the movie
um and uh and so he the ability to have
a Clear Vision but to also be open is
something that is really uh tricky and
hard to do but
um you know the great ones do it and
Josh uh really did my name is Miles
Morales I'm Brooklyn's one and only
Spiderman only that uh we're gonna take
the time it it needs for it to be uh
great and satisfying conclusion
to the trilogy uh and uh
and we'll let you know when uh when we
know more
but everyone's working really hard on it
and doing really I've already done a lot
of really wonderful work I'm lost
you can do anything you want this beer
doesn't taste good but I like how it's
making me feel I mean part of me is like
what does Garfield really sound like if
he wasn't you know what I mean if he was
R-rated because I actually think
Garfield is R-rated
and he just had to get censored he had
to censor a lot of his inner thoughts
that jumped to mine somebody mentioned
me recently because I certainly thought
about Ted another wonderful Universal
classic not an animal but I wouldn't
have minded if during the mushroom trips
they winded up interacting with Ted the
bear but you know unfortunately the idea
came too late in the creative process
but uh maybe next one you are officially
straight that would mean
duck doesn't
love poor little guy I should probably
talk to him I am a therapy dog I mean
they all were so dialed in
um and in any given turn they would
impress me so many so many different
ways
I I actually am going to give you a
weird answer
um
but
I I Think It's tricky to become a a
dirty couch who is breaking up with a
dog because uh he you discover he's
cheated on you with other couches so I
was kind of really Blown Away with Sofia
Vergara's commitment to being a couch
breaking up with her dog but it's a
tough question it's like asking me my
favorite child it's like there's no
there's no easy way out of that question
but I do I was blown away with Sophia's
commitment to that to that funny role
oh
he has changed my life he's uh I gotta
be honest I wish he was more like Reggie
in the movie he's a little more like bug
I think he's got a lot more attitude
than Reggie in the movie but no he's so
sweet I brought him home I surprised my
twin daughters we have a hilarious
adorable video of them opening a box and
losing their minds and um yeah I've got
you know I've had dogs my whole life
I've never had a terrier so you know
word to the wise they they have a lot to
say you know I've always had like sort
of dogs that don't bark a lot he's got a
lot to say so that's interesting but no
we absolutely love him such a joy there
was another dog adopted on the film by
another producer and just yesterday I
had them re-meet each other they hadn't
seen each other in a couple years so we
met up at the dog park which was fun but
no my my Reggie who my daughters of
course aptly named Reggie uh is just is
just such a joy to have in our house
having Will Ferrell run around your
house is quite fun going back to Doug's
what
did with the only the only thing he
truly loves
God yes although here's a fun wrinkle
he our dog was from the UK it turns out
Border Terriers are very hard to find
they're not a popular breed in the U.S
and they're used to play mutts right
because they kind of look like a mixed
breed so he's British so I guess he's
like a British Will Ferrell so maybe
he's like Sherlock Holmes I don't know
he's like
maybe I have will playing Sherlock as a
dog in my house yeah I'm star short for
Starbucks assume yours is Barbara nope
just Barb plain old Barb I think they
could potentially have turned into the
two turtles sea turtles that were on
Trisha's side
so maybe there's sea turtles out in the
ocean and they're teamed up with Trish
to go maybe like fight crime underwater
and they have a run-in with Morgan
Freeman the crab
and uh who didn't die you know if you
remember we thought he'd kill himself at
the end of that scene in barbin Star but
the twist is he actually was just going
out for a swim and now they're all out
in the sea together there we go Barb and
star two coming soon that's not what I'm
promoting go see straights